haiya Donald Trump and his White House
are immediately uncritically cheering
the exact same jobs numbers that under
Barack Obama Trump and his cronies were
calling fake and phony we learned a few
days ago that February saw 235 thousand
new jobs and a decrease of the
unemployment rate 24.7% Sean Spicer
tweeted great news for American workers
economy added 235 thousand new jobs
unemployment rate drops to four point
seven percent in first report for POTUS
Trump Trump chief of staff Reince
Priebus also taking to Twitter saying
POTUS Trump delivers in first jobs
report 235 thousand new jobs and
unemployment rate down to four point
seven percent great news for American
workers this is of course hilariously
embarrassing Lee laughingly hypocritical
because these are the same numbers that
when we were getting them under Obama
from the same organization the Bureau of
Labor Statistics they were fake phony
doctored unbelievable numbers according
to Trump in fact Donald Trump at an Iowa
rally after being elected in December of
2016 said quote so many people can't get
jobs the unemployment number as you know
is totally fiction they couldn't trust
the numbers before presented with the
unemployment rate Trumpets would say no
but look at the labor force
participation rate
I've debunked that a bunch of times the
labor force participation rate doesn't
take into account that we have more baby
boomers retiring that if the economy is
good and only one of two people in a
spousal situation might have to work
that decreases the labor force
participation rate but it's not
indicative of a bad economy I mean
totally debunk able easily debunk able
conspiracy theory but you still would
hear fake phony numbers look at the
labor force participation rate we
actually have a clip of White House
press secretary Sean Spicer being asked
why what's changed why do you believe
the numbers now when you didn't before
he basically laughed it off and
White House press room allowed him to
take a look at this president is
referred to particular job reports as
phony or totally fiction does the
president believe that this jobs report
was accurate and a fair way way to
measure the economy yeah I talked to the
president prior to this and he said to
quote him very clearly they may have
been phony in the past but it's very
real now yes very very funny the press
let him do it Pat and it's pathetic
it is absolute political pandering and
it's just it's embarrassing but they
have no shame do they I mean it's
getting to a point now where Donald
Trump's contradictions are kind of
expected so I don't know if there's even
a sense in calling them out anymore
because they don't even acknowledge them
and you know it gets to a point where
they're just laughing at the press
secretary there he's kind of going along
with it but what else can he really do
yeah I mean I guess you're right maybe
the laughing is not allowing him to do
it but laughing at him and realizing
they're not gonna get anywhere
absolutely pathetic all of a sudden the
numbers aren't fake and phony anymore if
you're hiring you've probably realized
that posting your job in just one place
really isn't enough to find quality
candidates if you want to find better
candidates you should be posting on all
of the top job sites which you can with
zip recruiter which is sponsoring
today's program zip recruiter already
has nine million resumes that you can
search through you can add multiple
people to your account and make it an
efficient hiring team and with zip
recruiter com you can post to 200 plus
job sites including social media
networks like Facebook and Twitter with
one click zip recruiter also has a
search engine for finding and posting
jobs you can look for candidates in
particular cities in specific industries
nationwide and then you can use the zip
recruiter interface to watch the
candidates roll in screen the candidates
and ultimately make the right decision
no juggling emails or phone calls to
your office and what are the best things
about the zip recruiter system is if you
have any issues at all their support
staff is not only friendly it is also
actual people humans that are ready to
help you you can find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by over in
million businesses and you can post jobs
on zip recruiter for free if you go to
zip recruiter dot-com forward slash free
trial once again try zip recruiter free
at zip recruiter dot-com slash free
trial